to me this team accomplished more almost
than any team
no disrespect to any other teams that we
had or any championship teams
but this team won 11 sec games no other
team has done that
now they won the sec and went undefeated
in the sg
and then they beat two great teams in
the playoffs
with the break in between now this is
our fifth game in a row
from lsu to arkansas to florida to notre
dame to here
and played 13 games went undefeated
with all the disruption that we had in
this season
i think there's quite a bit to write
about when it comes to the legacy of a
team
there's nick saban and yes that man just
won his seventh national championship
and his demeanor was i would describe it
as
slightly perturbed chris that's
to eight as you're ever gonna see right
nick saban we're on to number eight
and let's let's go and let's not spend a
lot of time
i look it takes that level of torment to
achieve that level of success
you can never pause you can never
be content you can never be satisfied
you have to constantly be striving for
more
the struggle the pursuit is where the
satisfaction lies and it's on to the
next one and it's warped and it's
twisted and it's not healthy
but he's won seven national
championships because of it
yeah he's one of the greatest coaches of
all time i mean if not the greatest
college coach of all time but i mean
he's in the conversation for just great
coach
any sport whatever it is you know
part of the bill belichick tree
sometimes that kind of guns
goes unnoticed right but they have the
same demeanor
you know and that same approach where
it's like okay yeah we won
we won the super bowl we won the
national championship it's great we'll
you know
have a beer and enjoy it but you know
the next day it's going to be on to the
next
season let's go but what they've done
what he's done
personally is unreal the fact that they
have won
what six national titles since 2009
the fact that you know they've been in a
number of other
national title games or the final four
games and lost to some freaky clemson
teams who were stacked and everything
like that i mean
you know i don't know there's definitely
hasn't been a run like this i guess the
alabama teams of the 60s and 70s maybe
the only team you in your lifetime that
you could say had a run like this
especially in college football yeah but
there was nothing like this even then
there was a handful of great teams right
it always kind of worked its way out and
it would be somebody different every
year there was never this year in and
year out can they please stop it
type of dominance and i think back to
december of 2006 and nick saban's
notorious i'm not going to be the
alabama coach when he was the dolphins
coach he was the second choice after
west virginia's rich rodriguez
rich rodriguez said no thank you to mal
moore the athletic director at the time
the university of alabama before they
made the push for nick saban
and saban before we anoint him as the
greatest coach of all time
we have to peel back
this notion that
it's the recruiting ability in college
it's that power to go out and get
yourself 10
round picks every year not one
that sets him apart and look
whatever it takes that's the rules
that's where i have my skill set that's
where i'm going to excel
i'm going to get these guys to come to
alabama and cluster there
and we're going to have a great team and
the x's and o's really don't mean all
that much
when my talent is so much superior to
your talent
okay fine he pulled it off he cracked
that code but the cody couldn't crack
and the cody didn't even want to try to
crack beyond two seasons was the nfl
code
where the talent is flat and where the
coaching is more important and you can't
be content for a minute or two while you
move on to the next championship at the
nfl level the best
that we've ever seen there is one out of
three
over a 20-year period which i don't
think nick saban would even be satisfied
with if he could have even gotten to
bill belichick's height
so there's still that defect
in the nick saban coaching legacy it's
that
that spot on the hood of the car that he
was washing as a kid at his dad's
service station and his dad would point
out to him good job but there's still a
spot on the hood of your car
the spot on the hood of nick saban's
resume is he failed at the nfl level
and we can't forget that no matter how
many national championships he wins well
yeah i i understand that you know i mean
bill belichick failed in cleveland and
with that experiment it wasn't perfect
for him his
his skill set the way but he didn't run
he didn't run to the naval academy he
didn't run to the naval academy for 20
years and never come back well
nick saban had already been in the
college is kind of where he had kind of
set his place in the college football
coaching world
and i think probably yeah at some point
okay right he wasn't perfect
for the nfl you know i think we could
take bill belichick to college and i
might go up i don't know perfect
he's eight and eight okay that's not
horrible i mean
you know well i don't know he didn't
stay long he went
back and dominated college football like
we've never seen before
so let's just talk about that instead of
nitpicking about something about 15
years ago it's not
holy crap it's not nitpicking it's not
nitpicking yes
you're the one that said the greatest
coach of all yes he is
there isn't no he's the greatest
recruiter of all time mike
migration he's adapted better than
anybody ever
you don't just win by recruiting you
recruit different
nfl players too he beats them almost
every year the sec is full of nfl
players
it's all the nfl he beats them every
year he adapts
he's continued to push the limits he be
he
he came from mark ingram smash mouth
football
trent richardson and now you see them
yesterday they're the kansas city chiefs
and they're going every which way and
throwing balls and reverses and
everything like that
he's a phenomenal exercise coach
phenomenal stop it
i would say maybe he's got some
phenomenal exes and those coaches
working for him his primary skill
is recruiting look hey chris we are
emissaries of the national football
league
and it's not like we we have to
like fake it it's the highest level of
competition i know it's the flattest
it's the flattest talent differential in
in any level of
football by far you know there's
hundreds of college football programs
there's maybe two that he has to worry
about
every year otherwise they just show up
and they they can yell out their plays
to the other teams even in the sec
and they ain't going to stop them
because of the superior talent
that he has recruited and i'm not taken
away from the fact
that he has been the best recruiter
we've ever seen but let's not call him
the best coach of all time because
most of the work is done before the
opening kick off and happen mike
is done it's all him it's it's all him i
mean steve sarkeesian he's running
he's he's changed as a play caller it's
all him
of everything he does their coaching is
through the roof good
i know it didn't work out in the nfl to
what we thought it might or
where he is as far as the pantheonic
coaches and all of that
i still think if he hung in the nfl hey
i'm one that would say
he would have won a championship at some
point i i don't
i'm like i'm not going to doubt that
what do you base that on what do you
base that on uh
what did you do two years ago the nine
championships that he has in college
football that's what i base it on those
hey hey how about this how about this
how about the decision
to trade a second round pick for dante
culpepper instead of sign drew breezy
still tries to blame on the doctors okay
like the doctors wouldn't i don't
know i was if he wanted to do that are
you somebody
you triggered me by saying greatest
coach of all time not the greatest coach
of all time bill belichick is
okay greatest college coach of all time
mike he's in the conversation there
that's great
and bill belichick failed in cleveland
too all right
so what i mean yes right okay sorry mike
sorry greatest college coach of all time
in the conversation
with the greatest coaches in any sport
ever
nick saban's involved in that nick
saban's in there and he's towards the
top of the conversation
so there i don't know what else to say
look i'll i'll agree with you college
football
yes but and he had his chance in the nfl
he ran away after two years and he made
a horrible decision
one of the worst quarterback decisions
of all time
when he picked dante culpepper and
surrendered a second round pick with a
wrecked and destroyed knee over drew
brees who had a wrecked and destroyed
shoulder
but what are we talking about
with drew brees first ballot hall of
famer one of the greatest quarterbacks
of all time
and saban himself said a couple of years
ago that he still would have been the
miami dolphins coach although i don't
believe it
if they had signed drew brees and i'm
not buying the idea that it was anybody
but nick saban that said no to drew
brees and yes they don't take
okay fine so he made it oh
okay it's one mistake amazing
you know pretty big mistake the contrast
to me
is stunning and why can't we delve into
that
incredible college coach greatest
college coach of all time
mediocre at best you know i mean i don't
i can't even
judge him as an nfl he wasn't there long
enough to
even judge it right it's not is that
we've seen
carol johnson okay
i understand here's my point we talked
not that long ago about
how it's admirable for guys to be
so grossly competitive about everything
they do
and and it occurred to me during that
conversation
you know when kids act that way we
discourage it
right when little jimmy has to win at
everything to the point where he's a
little pain in the ass
we say that's an objectionable character
trait but we applaud it in grown men
who have to crush everyone in everything
they do
it's a weird contrast and that came to
mind for me
because because you're crushing a guy
that won a national championship and
everything he's done is that why it came
to mind because you're doing that right
now
it came to mind because little nikki in
miami couldn't win the way he wanted to
so he took his ball and his bat and he
ran back to college football that's just
that's not
his like bull crap that's important like
he ran away from it like he was excited
he true comment but like you're he did
he did you're acting like he was scared
and like oh no i'm like
so outmatched and everything i played
against nick saban twice those years
his defense was on the cutting edge of
the nfl at the time already he should
have stayed
okay so they didn't win mike should have
come back just like some politics
he doesn't give a damn what you think
and you're wrong he's one of the
greatest coaches of all time i say any
sport
not even close it's not even a
conversation i like hey
hey it's not a conversation where the
players get paid i like football where
the players are okay
that's great we know you do and it
doesn't change
they're still kids and look at how they
get treated they get no money they get
yelled at by their coaches like save and
i mean it's one thing for saban to yell
at an nfl guy
you're yelling and screaming at these
kids who aren't being paid so
that let's that's a different debate
because you've changed it
off the topic of him not being you're
changing the topic he's the greatest
one of the greatest coaches of all time
just say it just say it
that's all there is to it greatest he's
the greatest college
football coach of all time at the nfl
level
he gets i don't even get a d great
he gets an incomplete great because he
ripped up the test
his overall grade is a 99.9 as a coach
period it doesn't matter okay he's got
two years in
miami hey chris chris he's got an
easy way for him to prove me wrong easy
way there's seven openings right now in
the nfl take one of them let's see what
you can do nick
why would you usually climb the same
dame mountain over
because you've got you've gotten this
you've beat bear bryant you're the best
college
coach of all time you're not going to
get any better you know there's no one
else
hey brady you're the best of all talking
to the nfl don't even play anymore
i mean no why would he leave something
where he's got a
uh he's he's going to continue to have
the greatest legacy ever
why that makes no sense you're arguing
argue on a tuesday morning that's all
you're doing no no i'm not
no i'm not this is what i believe and
i've believed it for a long time
and you drew it out in me today you
turd you it's your fault you said so
the point is the point is there are
seven openings right now in the nfl if
he wants to prove himself to be the
greatest coach of all time in any sport
come back to the nfl i'd like to see him
back in the nfl
as salty and as prickly as he is i like
that
i like i like the oh yeah he's just like
you he's
all like prickly just like you shocker
you guys are from west virginia i mean
i'm really surprised i'm i'm shocked
he grew up he grew up 20 minutes away
from damn it must be in the water
i'm not going to fawn all over the guy i
mean let's i'm i
there is a defect in his resume and it's
his two years at miami
okay that's not going anywhere he can
win he can win 10 more national
championships and that's not going
anywhere that's all i'm saying
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports